انا عندي متلازمه وانا جاهز طبيعي يعني
شخص طبيعي اعطوني فرصه
محمود سعدون الشمري
طالب موارد بشريه وعندي نوع من المتنجمات
[موسيقى]
تتبرع من متلازمه تداوم لكن انا اللي فيني
بالضبط اللي هو عدم تعرف مشاكل مثلا
بالجلد
الحساسيه او الحساسيه تقريبا
انا تاخرت بالدراسه
وعشان ادخل مع اخوي مره واحده انا بيني
وبينه تخلص
[موسيقى]
وجهنا المجتمع سوا بشكل عام هذا بدايه
جديده او بحكم انه يعرفونه بالمدرسه بشكل
عام حكم التواصل يعني
مثلا مع مدرسين يبون يعرفون بالضبط كيف
بيواجه المجتمع وما اشوف الا لا حاجه يعني
بخصوص انه انا منذ الصغار لما اواجه مجتمع
كثير راح اتعلم يعني راح تقبل كل شيء
شغلنا هذا الشيء خطا ليش لانه انا لما
مثلا لما ادخل معك خاص العاديين ضحكت
راح اكون شخص عادي وراح اواجه مثلا التنمر
عادي بالعكس لاني انا اول ما اطلع من
المدرسه
الاشخاص مثلا
اللي هو مدرسه معينه طبيعيه كل الاشخاص
اللي فيها طبيعيه هل الخمس اشخاص هذه
قادرين انه ياثرون على ال300 طالب مثلا
اكيد لا اكيد انه 300 طالب هم اللي راح
ياثرون عليها اللي هو يعتبر المشكله بشكل
عام
فلما يتحدث انا راح اتطور منه
تطور مهارات اكتب خباته شكلها
[موسيقى]
احد الوالدين يعني مثلا يقول انت ما فيك
شيء انت شخص طبيعي يعني
من الافضل انه تعلموا ايش اللي عندهم وش
اللي هو يمضي فيها وش ذا في اساليب معينه
انه لو قالوا انه انت عندك مثلا كذا وكذا
بس هذا الشيء انه ما يعيطك انك تمارس تعمل
كذا هذا افضل بكثير
مثلا هذا الشخص قاعد يكتب عليه انه هو في
شيء بس مو قاعد يقول بس محاوله فهم ايش
كذا يعني
ما عرفت حالتي الا بالاخير
فهذا كان
عند الله طلع بريك فسحه
يجتمعون علي طلاب المدرسه بشكل كامل
[موسيقى]
كل واحد من الطلاب يدف الجميله علي ودافع
التخوير
هذا شخص يعني زي ما تكونون مثلا بدون
حواجب بدون اسنان او شيء كنت اقابلهم بين
فتره وفتره معينه يعني كنت اشوف حداهم
بالشارع كانوا هم اللي يتذكرون على ما
اتذكر للامان
كان
سامحنا الكلام عن
يعني مثلا لما يشوف انه هذا شخص يعني كيف
شكل كذا يحسب انه لما
يمسكني او سلم علي هذا الشيء يعني مثلا
يسلم او يمسح ايدينه بثيابه او شيء زي كذا
كنت احس انه انا يعني شخص
غريب انه ليش الناس يجتمعون شايفين انا ما
اشوفه
بحكم اني انا ما اتعرف
ما عندي مشاعر ما في اي شيء برد هذا الجسم
كان يقول الدكتور قبل
الماء هذا ما يلقى مكانه صارت معاه ممكن
يدخل مع الدم سبب
طبيعيه الله سبحانه
انه ممكن ما نكمل
يعني هذا قضاء القدر بشكل عام لكن الشاي
مثلا مر على مريت عليها انا ما ودي انه
يعيد هالشيء هذا لابنا
[موسيقى]
الغرض متلازمه اطلق المسمى هذا انه كشخص
نفسه ياخذ حقوقه
كمتلازمه يعني لكن انه في ناس مثلا يقول
هذا عنده اعاقه او
اعاقه جسديه او فكريه سؤال كذا ولا كذا
اللي يحسب انه هذا مو قادر على العمل مو
قادر على داء الوظيفه ومقاد اظنه يؤدي
مهاره كنت استحي من الناس
انه انا عندي شيء
انه عندي مشكله شخصيه انه مثلا صحيه او
شيء زي كذا يعني انه حارس انه ما تنقل
الصوره دي
ما تنزل لي اي صوره
زملاء ما يسخرون
يمدح الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله قريب